Alright, so we have installed, GitHub locally, which
gives us a place to put our files.
>> Mm-hm.
>> We have an account, which gives us a place online to
have our files. How do we get them to talk to each other?
>> Okay. Well, we're going to need to, sign in. So, let's go to Preferences.
>> Okay.
>> Alright. So, yeah we want to Allow that. Sure.
So that was something about how is sort of makes sure that it's us.
>> Okay, so now we can access any repositories
that we have here, but we don't have any yet.
>> Right so,
>> Go back.
>> Were going to need to go actually get the repository
>> Okay.
>> The original repository from GitHub. What
should I do? Search for that [CROSSTALK].
>> Yes
>> [BLANK_AUDIO]
Okay.
>> Alright, so we, so we found his repository.
>> Okay.
>> So there are two options here. We could clone it, which
means that we would just have a local version of his repository.
Or, we can Fork it which means that we make our own
copy of the repository that we can then put on our local machine.
>> Okay, and what should we do?
>> Since I don't think we, we want to make any changes to his repository,
I think we want to fork it so that we have our own totally separate one.
>> Okay.
>> [SOUND]
I like.
>> It's forking it.
>> I like it. So I'm going to Refresh, and there we go.
>> Alright, so now we have our own copy.
>> That is cool. So these are all those files that I had copied and
pasted before. The JavaScript files, the Style
files, and then this Index file. Very cool.
>> Yeah. So now if we go back over here and refresh, it shows up.
>> Awesome.
>> And we can clone it to our local machine. Alright,
so we now have a copy of the repository on our machine.
>> Okay, great.